this is Grandmaster Daniel nariditsky we
are watching Hikaru Nakamura taking on
Chinese Grandmaster luxion lake at the
2014 fide World Blitz championship and a
peaceful opening by Hikaru asifi and
ketos his Queen's Bishop at the very
start of the game Hikaru is an expert in
this opening he plays it very frequently
in Blitz and LU Chang lay already taking
10 seconds and developing his Bishop to
G4 the most aggressive the most
ambitious Square for his light scored
bishop and Hikaru with Knight E5 jumping
into the center this does resemble kind
of a reverse trumpowski but the big
difference that Hikaru already has
fiancattled his Bishop there goes Bishop
B2 and Lou shangley gets his night out
and offers a night trade which Hikaru
declines as he moves it back to F3 very
unique opening here and luxonglay
continues his development in hikarufian
ketoing his other Bishop now transposing
into something resembling a king's
Indian attack in D3 a typical move here
a sikaru castles and both sides
continuing to develop very very quick
quickly the Knight coming out to D2 and
Hikaru is probably going to try to push
his e-pawn as quickly as he can that
Bishop on D6 the Knight on F6 are also
going to be susceptible to a fork and so
luxion pushes his own Pawn to E5 and a
trade in the center a position that
Hikaru certainly likes he's also up 30
seconds on the clock he's basically
played instantly here he's got both of
his Bishops fiancuted he's got some
pressure on the E5 Pawn but luxon Lane
he has pressure corresponding pressure
on the E4 pun he plays Queen E7 he was
trying to trade dark squared Bishops
with Bishop A3 which Hikaru immediately
prevents by pushing his own Pawn out to
A3 and now luxion Lee probably trying to
figure out how to position his Rooks he
just seems uncomfortable though he's
already taken almost a minute off of his
clock and we're still in the opening
Hikaru with a lot of clearly defined
ideas here that knight from F3 it could
jump to H4 and to F5 and icaro almost
seems bored he's so experienced in these
kinds of positions and now his time
Advantage has reached one minute with
still over three minutes on the clock is
trying to expand on the queen side here
pushing his Pawn out to A6 maybe
preparing B7 B5 and trying to stop
hikaru's D2 knight from accessing C4 But
Here Comes the other night and it jumps
out to H4 and the Bishop from D6
moves on to a more active square and
that's why luxion lay played A6 on the
previous move if Hikaru plays B4 he will
drop his Bishop back to A7 and keep it
on that diagonal in order to pressure
the F2 pawn and now wilhikaru put his
Knight on F5 yes he does offering a
trade of the light squared Bishop for
the night and luchangle declines that
trade instead choosing to move his Queen
up to E6 and he's sort of threatening to
take hikaru's Knight on F5 although that
pawn on B7 could hang at the end of that
line so Hikaru doesn't even really have
to defend the Knight if he doesn't want
to and he takes his first think of the
game and he plays Bishop H3 creating a
pit a pin against the queen and
threatening a discovered check and so
Lucien lay shifts his Queen over to C6 I
like the way he's handling the middle
game thus far but Hikaru continues to
expand and watch out that Bishop can't
drop back to A7 because there will be a
fork on E7 what a clever idea by Hikaru
and exasperation is seen on luciangle's
faces he will have to drop his dark
skirt Bishop back to a very passive
Square he certainly doesn't want to move
back to D6 and then Hikaru he could
continue expanding on the queen Side by
pushing his C Pawn to C4 this is
actually a very unpleasant position all
of a sudden for black and he looks over
at the clock and he changes his thinking
pose and luxion getting a little bit
nervous here I see Caro is fully in
control of the game and finally he
decides to bite the bullet and he takes
on F5 Hikaru recapturing with the pawn
in order to intensify the pressure on
the E5 pawn and create the possibility
of dropping his light squared Bishop
back to G2 and he doesn't do that yet as
he expands on the queen side pushing his
Pawn out to C4 and he's threatening C5
and so Luciano moves his Bishop outside
the gates with Bishop G2 Hikaru dropping
his light squared Bishop back onto the
long diagonal and continuing to expand
on the queen side and adding more
pressure and shoving that Queen and
forcing it back to A7 the situation
getting more and more unpleasant here
for luchang lay and after Hikaru trades
on D4 that pawn on D4 is going to be
really really weak and Hikaru is going
to surround it with his Knight and his
Rooks and there he goes and first he
surrounds it with his Queen and he moves
up to C4 still over two minutes on the
clock look at how confidently Hikaru
plays these positions and how does Lux
defend that pawn on D4 look at his Queen
on A7 it's totally banished it's out of
the game and that is not something that
he can afford as he drops now to below a
minute on the clock then the situation
continuing to deteriorate
for the Chinese Grand Master what does
he do here and he plays B6 desperately
trying to create some space for his
Queen and break through White's Pawn
chain on the queen side but Hikaru says
no way Jose and no way shangley here
Knight coming out to B3 and defending
the pawn on C5 and Hikaru recapturing
and at least luchang Li has managed to
isolate that pawn on C5 so Hikaru can he
take on D4 with his Queen if he takes
with a knight then he does allow black
to take the pawn on C5 and Hikaru now
taking perhaps one of the first thinks
of the game as he's played so quickly
and confidently and he's trying to
figure out whether he can take that pawn
on D4 I think he can I think he can just
take that pawn with his Queen but just
double checking that there's nothing
nasty that black can do because that
Queen will be walking into a potential
discovered attack by the Knight on D7
and the sicaro continues to think he
finally decides to First Trade Rooks
and force blackstruck off of the d8
square that actually makes a lot of
sense and now he has won the center Pawn
on D4 and Lou shangley down to 40
seconds as he swings his Rook back to B8
and he hits the Knight and if the Knight
moves away then the C5 Pawn is going to
be hanging so can Hikaru find a way to
keep his Knight anchored to B3 and yes
he does as he brings this queen calmly
back to C3 and look at that Bishop on G2
as it totally dominates over Black's
entire position the Knight on F6 the
queen on A7 nothing has any squares and
Lou shangley shakes his head as he moves
his Rook back from B8 into E8 and he car
now up a pawn for no compensation if
anything White's pieces are also much
better placed than luchang lay he needs
to pull a rabbit out of the hat but it's
looking increasingly unlikely as Hikaru
shoves his Pawn down a C6 and opens up
the C5 Square for his Knight and will he
put his Knight there and yes he does
with no hesitation Queen C8 by Lou
shangley attacking F5 and Hikaru defends
it and also attacks the A6 spawn at the
same time and H3 now he starts to expand
on the queen side and the Knight moves
to D7 so silky smooth as hikaru's
technique 15 seconds now for the Chinese
Grand Master and will he take that
Knight on D7 but then there's gonna be a
Pawn on D7 very close to promotion and
Hikaru will be able to support that pawn
from C6 with his Bishop if he so desires
and nothing better to do with four
seconds on the clock than to take the
Knight this position is completely
winning for Hikaru Bishop C6 or queen A6
everything looks overwhelming here and
there comes that Bishop as it sits on C6
and that Queen is going to infiltrate to
A6 and queen A8 is coming and a queen
trade is going to cause the pawn to
promote and Lux with his last second
moves his King up to H7 but there goes
Queen A8 and it's all over Lu xiangle
has to trade but now he cannot stop the
pawn he's gonna have to give his Knight
up and this is over Hikaru up a bishop
what a smooth positional game by the
blitz wizard Hikaru Nakamura if you
enjoyed this video make sure to click
the link of the playlist for more of
these videos thank you so much for
watching
foreign